les bleus ratent leur premier match dans
la coupe du monde à séoul les champions
du monde en titre ont été battus par le
sénégal à 0 la déception des supporteurs
français et à dakar explosion de joie
un pays en fait
après le drame de vitry les obsèques des
deux fillettes et de leur père couché
par une porsche ce dimanche dernier
immense émotion d'une population venue
témoigner de sa solidarité journée
mondiale sans tabac cette année elle est
dédiée au sport le ms qui estime que 4
millions de personnes chaque année
meurent de maladie consécutive à la
cigarette les campagnes comme s qui
commence tout de même à faire leur effet
la grande bretagne est à la parade à
partir de demain quatre jours de fête
pour le jubilé de la reine des
célébrations marquée par un immense
spectacle devant buckingham et la
traversée dans un carrosse doré de la
reine voilà monsieur bonsoir quelle
déception l'équipe de france championne
du monde n'a pas réussi son entrée dans
le mondial les bleus du pied gauche se
sont fait battre 1-0 par le sénégal une
surprise qu'il faudra dépasser l'absence
de zidane sur le banc de touche aura
sans doute joué reste la fougue de
l'équipe sénégalaise
les lions avaient tout à gagner et ils
ont réalisé leurs rêves marqués contre
les tricolores christophe différents la
france qui gagne c'est lui et lui tout
seul aussi heureux que chevelu bruno
metsu l'entraîneur français du sénégal
et les sénégalais fous de joie ils ont
battu la france championne du monde 1-0
surprise ou pas un point c'est tout mais
pour le sénégal c'est un joli point
d'honneur les bleus avaient un rang à
tenir le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas tenu leur province ou
bien sûr parfois sa tenue a rien à ce
tir de trezeguet qui s'écrase sur le
poteau
une demi heure de jeu les bleus commence
par perdre bêtement le ballon le très
talentueux al hadji diouf déborde franck
leboeuf et sans c'est peut-être la faute
à pas de chance ce ballon qui touche
petit et qui échappe à fabien barthez
mais bouba diop marque le premier but de
la coupe du monde les lions du sénégal
danse à séoul et mène à la mi-temps 1 à
0 marabout bout de ficelle en deuxième
période les bleus retrouvent un poil
d'énergie mais à chaque fois c'est
l'énergie du désespoir car en dépit des
quelques occasions le score des
tricolores ne dépassera jamais le zéro
la france a connu un jour sans un jour
sans but sans inspiration mais pas sans
reproche
il suffit de voir la tête des bleus de
zizou qui faisait banquette et de roger
lemerre qu'on a connu plus souriant à la
fin du match dans un coin de tribune
un supporter de chez nous a les larmes
aux yeux et l'on se dit que pour le foot
français
ce n'est plus tous les jours fait
messages de soutien et d'amitié de
jacques chirac l entraîneur roger
lemerre il faut dépasser cet échec dit
l'elysée
dès que zizou sera là en scène jean
pierre raffarin ça ira mais après le
match ça n'allait pas vraiment les bleus
font grise mine reportage florent
gautreau anda germain les français n'ont
pas traîné au stade et le bus a vite
regagné leurs pairs des bleus vrai c'est
d'oublier la défaite pressé aussi de
trouver du réconfort auprès de leurs
épouses
invité par la fédération sans un mot
visage fermé et roger lemerre et les
champions du monde sont allés dîner
c'est la soupe à la grimace pour les
joueurs et dirigeants eux font toujours
confiance aux bleus
moi je suis de ceux qui regardent
l'histoire en face à la coupe du monde a
pris 1,18
quelquefois la chance nous a aidés à
l'euro 2000
quelquefois nous a aidés aujourd'hui
elle n'était pas avec nous mais moi que
ça va nous faire prendre conscience que
le groupe doit se serrer les rangs et
puis gagner les deux prochains vainqueur
au mondial 98 de l'afrique du sud et à
l'euro 2002 danemark l'équipe de france
est confrontée pour la première fois
depuis quatre ans à une défaite précoce
en compétition inévitablement un débat
va s'engager sur les retouches à
apporter au groupe
certains titulaires ont du souci à se
faire et la soirée est resté maussade
jusqu'au bout puisque c'est la pluie qui
a accueilli les bleus à leur retour à
l'hôtel
ils ont d'abord dîner avec leurs épouses
ou leurs compagnes
puis ensuite c'est quartier libre ce
soir mais on imagine que la soirée ne
sera pas très gai après la défaite il ya
une question qui hante déjà toute la
délégation française est ce que zidane
va pouvoir jouer le deuxième match
contre l'uruguay
c'est certainement ce qui va hanter la
nuit de roger lemerre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut maintenant que les
bleus gagnent leurs deux prochains
matchs contre l'uruguay et contre le
danemark dans le stade archicomble de
séoul les supporteurs venus encourager
chacun à leur équipe n'ont pas regardé
le match de la même façon que landes ce
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe rochot et sylvain sûr
mais on a perdu ça n'est pas la marche
funèbre mais ça lui ressemble comme si
les supporters des bleus présents à
séoul avait déjà enterré la coupe de
bons milieux candidats intéressés là on
voit aujourd'hui ça manque sexy zidane
avait été là ça serait passé autrement
et il manque quand même des bons joueurs
carmat népal qui motive et qui pour
l'impression qu'il manque un peu de
confiance en soi
les supporters sénégalais elie que rien
qui les ont soutenus n'en croyait même
pas leur jeu je passe maintenant du
monde
l'ico rien eu même qu'ils ont pu voir le
match sur des écrans géants répartis à
travers la ville avait plutôt parié sur
une victoire des français car ici le
sénégal n'est guère connu et ils se sont
passionnés pour ce premier match de la
coupe et le but sénégalais
un match venu en apothéose d'une folle
journée où l'on aura vu plus de 60000
personnes gagner le stade par le métro
et se placer sans incident majeur
des forces de police avec deux mille
hommes canaliser cette foule le passage
obligatoire des spectateurs au détecteur
de métaux a été efficace et les 9000
personnes placées sur la liste noire
n'ont pas pu venir ici perturber ce
match d'ouverture
inutile de dire que le sénégal ce soir
est en fait l'euphorie dès le coup de
sifflet final la joie se lit sur tous
les visages et un sentiment de fierté
nationale souligne la victoire méritée
des lions la nuit promet d'être longue
sur place eric meunier bruno girodon
le match lui-même n'avait rien d'amical
les propos d'avant-match à dakar ce
matin entre supporters il était tout à
fait pour sa première participation à la
phase finale d'une coupe du monde tout
le sénégal s'était parée des couleurs
nationales on avait déserté les écoles
les entreprises les administrations pour
se rassembler devant les écrans de
télévision au café de la poste
personne ne doute de la victoire des
lions de la teranga le surnom de
l'équipe sénégalaise alors quand à la
30e minute pas bouba diop pousse la
balle dans les filets français
à la mi-temps les supporters semblent
déjà leur équipe invincible 15 devant
les grands écrans installés en ville
la foule suit la deuxième mi temps et
sans vraiment frémir jusqu'au coup de
sifflet final
en quelques minutes le centre de dakar
eu littéralement investi par les
supporters les supporters de tous âges
de toutes origines sociales
le match le plus important de la coupe
du monde
nous savons que nous avons pu nous
avions nos valeureux lions 1-3 les nous
avons gagné le contre ne pas pas nuire
lyon le lion va manger le kof révisé la
rue ces dernières semaines il est
effectivement au menu ce soir la foule
certains rassemblés devant le palais
présidentiel comme c'est de tradition
après une victoire de l'équipe
sénégalaise est partout au sénégal
la fête ne fait que commencer ce soir et
je vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
le président sénégalais qui n'a jamais
douté de la victoire et qui partage la
joie de la population dans les rues tout
de suite après le match résume bien de
toi il est très douloureux c'est une
journée qui est unique
dada la vie d'un pays aujourd'hui en
battant l'équipe est championne du monde
le sénégal est cinquième du bois
jusqu'à la fin de la foux le sénégal est
championne du monde
voyons maintenant à paris comment alors
du déjeuner les supporteurs ont essayé
de renouer avec les moments de joie de
la dernière coupe du monde
mais l'enthousiasmé est vite retombé
manuel tissier christophe vignal
l'histoire ne se répète pas mais ce
n'est pas faute d'avoir essayé
la place de l'hôtel de ville retrouve
ses maquillages tricolore ces drapeaux
sa foule prête à bondir comme en 98 5000
personnes dans le centre de paris un peu
plus encore au pied des tours de la
défense
costume cravate ou tailleur et quelques
maillots bleus un peu de temps volé au
travail de bureau
j'en profite manière h est pas là et en
plus il était prévu qu'on le voit dans
la boîte le match qui s'avère que les
réseaux télé fonctionne pas donc chacun
fait comme il peut j'ai pris une réunion
à 2h30 simplement
donc j'ai encore un peu de temps 14h sur
l'écran la défense française vient de
craquer sur le parvis
le sénégal en flammes la défense
mon coeur battait quand même pour
l'équipe la plus faible donc la france
hélas aujourd'hui la série super mais je
sais que la france va se qualifier la
france était bien la plus faible
aujourd'hui mais la vie continue
retour au bureau la pause est terminé
les matches de la coupe du monde se
déroule le compte tenu du décalage
horaire à l'heure du déjeuner un peu
après les entreprises pour certaines ont
permis un aménagement des horaires pour
laisser leurs salariés regarder le coup
d'envoi du mondial claude marc david
cigale 13h30 dans sept grandes
entreprises les bureaux se vident les
bureaux mais pas l'amphithéâtre
aujourd'hui pas de conférences au
programme mais l'entrée des bleus dans
le mondial sur grand écran s'il vous
plaît
on sait que la coupe du monde c'est
important pour la moitié
si la totalité de l'entreprise savoir
que l'entreprise aussi se bouge pour
faire plaisir à ses employés c'est un
plus on n'est pas essayer d'écouter à la
radio en douce comme manager est pas là
au moins 106 elle c'est plus convivial
et a besoin de se cacher donc ou de
prendre un jour de congé pour 7 250 cab
leur directeur lui-même et dans la salle
pour supporter les français supporters
mais pas si on a d'ailleurs une limite à
la participation dans cet amphithéâtre
et bien à ça on a demandé à chaque
manager de s'assurer de la continuité du
service au client qui est bien sûr la
première de nos priorités et à l'étagé
on s'accommode plutôt bien de la
situation
et puis tous on a plein de travail et
puis comme ça on fait pas partie
papotant très fier on est super bien les
couilles à pas les garçons et oui les
privilégiés ne se rendent pas forcément
compte de leur chance car pour beaucoup
d'employés le salon c'est lé rayon hi-fi
des grands magasins ou encore le café du
coin il paraît qu'on en est partie
plutôt déçu déçu les amoureux de
l'équipe de france heureuse sénat bout
elle est salariée à paris et d'origine
sénégalaise
l'après midi c'est nabbous a dû avoir
bien du mal à reprendre son activité
pour elle la fête a commencé au travail
elle est sûrement loin d'être terminée
les coups de fil avec des collèges
maisons de retraite en passant par le
village natal de roger lemerre et les
français étaient enthousiastes puis
attentifs avant d'être déçu à mme guerry
or il est le grand du bonheur et du
bonheur sans retenue
les ulis en banlieue parisienne pendant
tout le match ils ont vibré à l'unisson
pour le sénégal enfin presque car ici
finalement les lions ou les bleus on les
aime tous très bien que les mails que le
meilleur gagne la france
mais c'est légal mais c'est leur premier
jeu contemporain et cela s'est vu ce but
il l'espérer temps sans vraiment y
croire
ah ah
c'est mon but excusez moi même trop
plein d'émotions à marseille mais avec
un soupçon de culpabilité au pays de
zidane on a eu l'impression de trahir un
peu les bleus mais enfin l'instant est
si rare je ne supporte que le scénarion
aussi la fin c'est le meilleur gagne là
c'est pour l'instant c'est le sénégal oh
là là ils vont marquer l'histoire à
dunkerque lui aussi a toutes les raisons
d'être fiers bruno metsu entraîneur des
lions sénégalais c'est son fils je sais
pas dans quel état d'esprit qui doit
être tout en étant rejoint les décors
assez stressé enfin chez les parents
adoptifs du lensois ferdinand coly
intégrés aux lions la joie se savoure
sans modération je tue franck g avant
tout mais bon mais moi j'ai le petit qui
est quelqu'un qui tue rappelé aux deux
jeux avant de refermer cette page
consacrée au mondial essayant de
remonter le temps et de nous remonter le
moral bien des équipes en subit le même
échec que les bleus en ouverture ce
qu'ils a pas empêché de s'imposer par la
suite d'un match catastrophe à la
possible victoire 6-1 et chant pour les
équipes championnes du monde en titre
jouant le match d'ouverture
la vie n'a pas toujours été rose plein
de réussite et de fleurs des champs
mondial-1990 l'argentine de maradona est
favorite mais la tête domaine be geek
est au fond des filets le cameroun
l'emportent 1 à 0 et pourtant et
pourtant
l'argentine va se qualifier et atteindre
la finale
déjà en 82 l'argentine tenante du titre
s'est incliné face à la belgique
mais passé malgré tout le premier film
en 86 l'italie obtenu un difficile match
nul contre la bulgarie
un autre nul dans son deuxième match
puis une victoire dans le troisième pour
finalement se qualifier tout de même la
défaite en ouverture n'a donc rien de
rédhibitoire pour continuer l'aventuré
malgré tout un champion outragé d'entrée
n'a jamais remporté la victoire finale
l'actualité de ce vendredi les obsèques
à choisy le roi des fillettes et de leur
mère fauché par une porsche dimanche
dernier à vitry sur seine le chagrin sur
tous les visages la révolte dans le
coeur toute une population venue
témoigner de sa solidarité au rigi ma
mathieu dreujou philippe morin
anaëlle cinq ans maeva 3 ans et leurs
mamans jenny elles étaient ses deux
filles et sa compagne c'est à elle qu'il
adresse ces quelques mots à elle est mal
bord ce sont leurs poulets vous à cet
apport a le sens du monde de milan - sur
le parvis de la cathédrale saint-louis
quelques 300 personnes ont assisté aux
obsèques
beaucoup ne connaissaient pas la famille
mais ont tenu à partager la douleur et
exprimer leur compassion
je ne sais pas comment vous dire c'est
des frissons c'est trop dur trop dur
trop duré
sanchez que je voudrais faire en fait
parfois même à la place des gens ont
perdu leurs
c'était vraiment vraiment présent
aux côtés des proches la foule a
accompagné maeva anaëlle et jenny
jusqu'au bout et dans le plus grand
silence après le braquage d'un fourgon
blindé hier près d'evreux au moins six
personnes munies d'armes de guerre ont
participé à cette opération minutes et
s'aperçoit qu'il n'a pas fait de
victimes c'est ce qu'a indiqué
aujourd'hui le procureur de la
république ajoutant que les malfaiteurs
étaient constitués en bande organisée ou
moins trois équipes à bord de trois
voitures différentes du travail de vrais
professionnels situation de crise après
l'affrontement hier à bayonne entre crs
et médecins l'heure est à la polémique
entre la coordination nationale des
généralistes et la cnam chacun sa
version des faits et en toile de fond
des revendications qui n'ont pas encore
abouti peggy droit le conventionnement
la consigne n'a pas changé et la
coordination nationale des médecins
généralistes porte parole ainsi que des
confrères à poursuivre la mobilisation
contre la caisse d'assurance maladie
une façon de protester contre les
incidents d'hier après midi à bayonne
200 médecins étaient venus réclamer
devant la caisse primaire la levée des
sanctions pour des collègues appliquant
déjà la consultation à 20 euros après
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
huit médecins ont été blessés ainsi que
trois policiers avant les législatives
le nouveau gouvernement voulait
désamorcer le conflit des médecins c'est
raté
après ce couac nicolas sarkozy a invité
ce matin les portes paroles des
généralistes au ministère de l'intérieur
l'occasion pour les médecins d'hausser
le ton contre la cnam et contre son
président une femme lassée de ce
mouvement
nous sommes encore plus déterminés
maintenant et nous demandons
premièrement la démission de monsieur
fait et ce dans un but d'apaisement
deuxièmement nous appelons mardi
prochain à une journée santé morte en
france tous les cabinets seront permet
malgré la tension entre les médecins et
la caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
leur rencontre mardi est toujours
maintenue
ça y'est nicole notât a passé le
flambeau à son successeur françois
chérèque il prend donc la tête de la
cfdt discours de clôture du 45e congrès
de la confédération avec un vidéo clip
retraçant la carrière de nicole notât
l'hommage de la salle les
applaudissements des militants
le premier ministre était aujourd'hui
dans le aura pour un meeting sur le
thème de la lutte contre la précarité et
l'exclusion jean pierre raffarin qui
annonce dans une interview à paraître
demain dans ouest france qu'il n'y aura
pas de coup de pouce au smic le 1er
juillet prochain sans en mesurer les
conséquences sur l'emploi
jacques chirac demande aujourd'hui une
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
ce texte qui concerne la période 2003
2008 sera examiné par le parlement avant
la fin de l'année il s'agit d'augmenter
les crédits le budget d'équipement des
armées
à huit jours du premier tour des
législatives carnet de campagne à
ajaccio au coeur du débat bien sûr le
processus de matignon
décrié par les uns et soutenu par les
autres dans cette circonscription où la
bataille s'annonce serrée arnaud goûter
raymond chatard avec les divisions de la
droite simon renucci
imaginez volontiers sa campagne comme
une promenade presque tranquille des
palmiers d'ajaccio jusqu'au velours de
l'assemblée mais pour le nouveau maire
divers gauche
la chute du candidat jospin a quelque
peu grippé la machine
simon renucci part seule au combat et
lorsqu'il vante le processus de matignon
les ajacciens préfèrent parfois entendre
un autre discours
soyez députés m
je crois qu est la ville parce que vous
impliquez énormément mais pour l'avenir
de la corse simon renucci souhaite
malgré tout poursuivre la réforme jospin
qui implique une nouvelle étape en 2004
ce serait antidémocratique que de
renoncer à un chemin que nous avons
construit entre l'immobilisme de la
violence
devant ses amis l'autre grand défenseur
du processus de matignon tient
aujourd'hui un autre discours campagne
oblige le député sortant josé rossi
critique la gauche et veut croire que
jacques chirac n'oubliera pas le dossier
corse jacques chirac enfin à droite
propose un grand projet décentralisateur
comment voudriez vous que je ne me
réjouis pas de cette situation je
sentiment que la corse a contribué à
déverrouiller le débat national sur la
décentralisation pour dénoncer le
processus de matignon le divers droite
marc marc angeli se place ni plus ni
moins dans le sillage de jacques chirac
difficile de s'y retrouver mais l'ancien
maire et surtout campagne contre josé
rossi responsable à ses yeux de son
échec aux dernières municipales côté
nationaliste on attend des cordes c'est
canadienne mais c'est surtout pire que
de jolis l'ancien chef du flnc qui se
retrouvent dans le grand bain sous le
soleil la bataille s'annonce serrée
et certains redoutent déjà la douche
froide et vous découvrez la liste des
autres candidates de cette
circonscription
concernant le chômage une baisse de 0 5%
en avril le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi diminué de quelque dix mille
quatre cents personnes par rapport au
mois précédent et c'est surtout le
chômage de très longue durée qui est en
recul la question de l'emploi hooker
bien sûr de la campagne électorale
chaque partie à travers ses candidats à
ces propositions sa formule solution
croisée de la gauche à la droite et
millet lançant eric mézil
les ouvriers de cette usine près de
fécamp croyait à l'avenir radieux de la
téléphonie mobile
aujourd'hui 4 138 emplois chez solectron
sont menacés l'usiné va fermer pour
délocaliser
là où la main d'oeuvre est moins chère
quel que soit le nouveau gouvernement il
sera attendu sur la question de l'emploi
si personne n'a de baguette magique
chaque formation politique propose des
solutions
les socialistes parie sur la croissance
et une politique volontariste
ils veulent augmenter le smic et les bas
salaires demandées aux entreprises de
rembourser les aides perçues si elles
délocalisent permettre l'accès à une
formation professionnelle tout au long
de la vie un coup de pouce tout
particulier est aussi prévue pour les
plus de 50 ans
ce que nous disons c'est que tous
chômeurs de plus de 50 ans doit avoir le
droit au retour à l'emploi dans
l'entreprise par un stage d'insertion
par une formation rémunérée ou par un
emploi aidé à droite du côté de l'union
pour la majorité présidentielle
on s'intéresse surtout aux jeunes l'idée
est de créer un contrat d'insertion pour
les moins de 25 ans en les aidant à
réaliser un projet l'ump propose aussi
le droit à de la formation continue en
entreprises et insistent sur la
nécessité de baisser les charges sur les
petits salaires nous pensons que pour
que l'emploi secret il faut qu'ils se
créent dans l'entreprise il faut donc
créer un environnement favorable en
baissant les charges sociales et en
particulier les charges sociales des
jeunes qui ont une formation bac + 2 -
le front national lui pour faire reculer
le chômage propose d'instaurer la
préférence nationale pour les salariés
français
il veut aussi créer un revenu parental
d'éducation et enfin abroger la loi
aubry sur les 35 heures quant à
l'extrême gauche elle préconise
l'interdiction des licenciements et une
participation la gestion d'entreprise
pour les salariés
le parquet de paris requiert un non-lieu
pour jean claude trichet gouverneur de
la banque de france qui avaient été
mises en examen dans l'enquêté sur les
comptes du crédit lyonnais
journée mondiale sans tabac avec pour
thème cette année le sport sans
cigarette le jour du coup d'envoi
d'ailleurs du mondial le ms qui estiment
à quelques quatre millions de personnes
chaque année le nombre de victimes du
tabac aujourd'hui les petits parisiens
d'en être convaincu que les adultes de
jeter leurs cigarettes en échange d'une
foyer cerises les diverses campagnes
anti tabac menée en france commencent à
porter leurs fruits c'est l'image de
marque du fumeur qui se modifie au fil
des ans la cigarette à la manne est plus
un geste noble l'hérault aujourd'hui
sont non-fumeurs année ce manteau
parlement et qu'il y à 40 ans les hommes
politiques n'hésitez pas à s'en griller
une petite devant les caméras la loyauté
que demander la la la cigarette n'était
pas un problème
ce dans la cour du ministère des
affaires sociales premiers arrivés
messieurs chirac secrétaire d'état à
l'emploi on s'affiche et facilement avec
des comics comme louis de funès en
faisait même de la pub mais visa mais il
y a quinze ans les mentalités changent
lucky luke sera le premier héros en
faire les frais il troque son ego
contraindre interne
la cigarette est fumeur c'est toujours
des toujours des grands mythes ses
ennemis du du cow boys du far west
aux etats-unis en france et le mythe un
petit peu de l'intellectuel avec la
cigarette brune hills et mitla ils ont
un petit peu éclaté quand est apparu un
peu partir des années 80 nouveaux modes
de vie on apprenait une vie plus saine
du plus sportive
voilà comme en 2002 on trouve des
restaurants branchés où il est
totalement interdit de fumer
ici aucun cendrier aucune cigarette
aujourd'hui le tabac est assimilée à une
drogue de nouveaux centres de
désintoxication ouvre peuple que vous
êtes en dû énerver de temps en temps est
ce vrai ici on suit médicalement et
individuellement ce qu'ils veulent
s'arrêter lorsque vous posez des
questions un petit peu beaucoup plus
fine vous trouvez toujours une grosse
bûche logique derrière
comme quoi pendant que le stress la peur
de rugby professionnel
la cigarette n'a plus la cote sauf chez
les jeunes à 19 ans la moitié d'entre
eux fument pour la clope c'est toujours
dans l'air du temps
il est dernier conseil de classe qui se
déroule en ce moment même à quelques
jours du bac la première épreuve celle
de philo aura lieu le 13 juin prochain
nabila taboury adèle juillet chant
réussi à pénétrer le saint des saints
chose est entendue à l'intérieur d'un
conseil de classe pour la vie pour le
bac couloirs vides et ambiance un peu
lourde
le rituel du conseil de classe a lieu à
chaque fin de trimestre professeur et
délégués sont réunis à huis clos
il ne s'agit pas de juger les lèvres on
constate son évolution mais cela ne se
fait pas sans une certaine appréhension
surtout 20 pour le procession du
professeur alain rousset pas une
surprise les connaissent douce
maintenant c'est savoir un buzz que
passer professeurs de haut c'est plutôt
ça qu'ils apprennent que le conseil de
classe c'est proprement même pour les
élèves de terminale le conseil de classe
du 3ème trimestre a son importance
al'approche du bac chaque élève aura
droit à un nazi doit faire ses preuves
favorables ou très favorables dans un
livret scolaire l'appréciation peut
faire la différence si de l'élève a eu
un accident dans une matière jury
regardera plus d'indulgence
le carnet scolaire pour éventuellement
ajouter des points pour obtenir le bac
ou même pour obtenir une mention par le
conseil de classe ne délivre jamais
d'avis défavorables de peur de démotiver
les élèves de terminale candidats au bac
certaines vitres ses preuves a vraiment
qu'on pouvait se dire ils sont désormais
trouver un bouc lapd a promis jeudi
l'uci fait qu'ils vont vraiment devoir
véritable course contre la montre les
conseils de classe doivent être bouclée
en fin de semaine prochaine et les
livret scolaire rempli avant l'épreuve
de philo le 13 juin prochain lendemain
d'élections en algérie une abstention
record qui marque le désintérêt ou la
défiance d'une partie de la population
quant au résultat du scrutin
c'est le triomphe sans surprise du fln
et le recul des islamistes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
thierry thuillier christian à la mosquée
rahma est trop exigu pour accueillir
tous les fidèles
il faut jouer des coudes pour trouver sa
place dans les rues de ce quartier du
centre d'alger
en ce vendredi de grande prière
lendemain d'élections les résultats oui
c'est la flemme alors on revient en 1962
le fln cas la majorité absolue mieux du
scepticisme à l'hostilité voici tizi
ouzou la kabyle
la ville est calme aujourd'hui dans la
région 97 % des électeurs se sont
abstenus
ce qui montre la détermination de la
population algérienne changé c'est pas
une victoire
le combat cantine s'il ya eu un
changement en algérie c'est bien la
reconnaissance officielle d'une
abstention record 47 % pour les plus
optimistes c'est la preuve de la
transparence du régime algérien
manipulation vous pensez bien que nous
avions plus aurions eu intérêt à gonfler
les chiffres
nous les avons congrès pour les
adversaires politiques du gouvernement
la question de la légitimité des
nouveaux députés est posée ils demandent
l'annulation du scrutin
abdelaziz bouteflika dispose désormais
d'une majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale qui lui permet de se passer du
concours des islamistes
une victoire politique donc mais qui
masque le fossé qui sépare aujourd'hui
en algérie la classe politique de sa
population au proche orient l'armée
israélienne a opéré aujourd'hui un coup
de filet à naplouse arrêtant une
centaine de personnes les militaires
sont entrés dans l'un des camps de
réfugiés celui de balata considéré comme
l'un des fiefs des brigades des martyrs
d'al-aqsa qui ont revendiqué l'attaqué
de mercredi
essai de naplouse que venait le jeune
kamikaze qui a provoqué l'attentât de
lundi dernier
les familles des victimes comme celle du
terroriste partage douleur et
incompréhension bertrand cocq philippe
gestion leur témoignage a bouleversé les
israël ce sont les parents de sinaï
la petite fille de 14 mois tué avec sa
grand-mère lundi par la bombe d'un
kamikaze près de tel aviv
ceux qui ont fait cela dit sa mère n'ont
aucun droit moral à quoi que ce soit
le garçon qui a tué leur fille est née
ici à balata un camp de réfugiés de la
banlieue de naplouse
il avait 18 ans il s'appelait jihad
comme la guerre sainte et voulait venger
son cousin tué quelques jours plus tôt
par les israël
la mère du kamikaze qui reçoit chez elle
les condoléances de ses amis dit qu'elle
avait senti que son fils allait tenter
quelque chose quand il l'a appelé avant
d'aller se faire sauter avec sa bombe
elle l'a félicité par avance et lui a
souhaité bonne chance
quant à la petite fille tuée dans
l'attentât
la mère de djihad dit qu'elle est une
victime de la politique de charonne
voilà donc une famille respectée qui a
ses martyrs s'est blessé aussi comme le
frère de djihad mounir paralysé depuis
qu'un éclat d'obus israéliens lui a
sectionné la moelle épinière
un cas d'école pour tous ceux qui
pensent que les récentes opérations
militaires n'ont fait que susciter des
vocations chez les jeunes palestiniens
ce sont les conditions de l'occupation
israélienne qui nous force à de tels
actes dits mounir nous n'aimons pas
infligé le mal nous ne sommes pas
assoiffé de sang ni amoureux de la mort
nous aussi nous aimons la yasser arafat
peut bien condamné les récents attentats
dont tous portent la signature des
brigades al aqsa ici à naplouse
le fatah retient un autre 10 ans nous
sommes fiers de nos martyrs des actes de
tous ceux qui se battent pour la
palestine
il répond ainsi au meurtre et à la
terreur d israël
et lorsque arafat qualifie ces actes de
terrorisme
arafat à ses propres conceptions de la
question nous avons les nôtres répond
l'homme du fatah ni la petite-fille de
tel aviv ni le jeune kamikaze de balata
ne pèse aujourd'hui sur la conscience
défiant chaque mort oblige les deux
camps à une tragique vendetta et jamais
la haine et l'incompréhension nom était
si profond le marché chinois eldorado
pour les entreprises françaises même
dans le secteur des télécoms
particulièrement sinistré alcatel vient
de mettre la main sur le numéro 2
chinois des équipements au moment où les
chinois se ruent sur les téléphones
portables reportage à shanghai
jean-paul chapelle jean-paul chaussée
shanghai 16 millions d'habitants
ici une personne sur trois possèdent un
portable et même les policiers sont
accros un appareil qui coûte en moyenne
1000 iwan l'équivalent de 1000 francs et
que l'on renouvelle de plus en plus
souvent c'est déjà mon sixième portable
à chaque fois il est de meilleure
qualité avec un écran plus grand et une
meilleure bête j'ai mon portable depuis
un an mais je vais en acheter un plus
moderne plus élégant en chine 10% de la
population atteint le niveau de vie
européen avec 130 millions d'abonnés
china mobile est déjà le premier
opérateur mondial
oui si la minute est facturé moins de 50
centimes de francs c'est très peu cher à
tel point que beaucoup optent pour la
téléphonie mobile et n'ont même pas de
téléphone fixe chez eux pour avoir sa
part du gâteau
alcatel a investi 300 millions d'euros
et pris le contrôle de shanghai bell le
numéro 2 chinois des équipements
la chine c'est c'est en train de devenir
le plus grand marché du monde
devant l'europe et les états unis à
terme de quelques années donc c'est
formidable s'est passé en échange le
français acceptent de partager tout ça
technologies
même la plus sophistiquée ici la
recherche a rattrapé le niveau
occidentale avec des ingénieurs payer
quatre fois moins résultat même dans ce
secteur de pointe
la chine commence à exporter maintenant
qu'elle est entrée dans l'organisation
mondiale du commerce la chine accepte
d'ouvrir progressivement son marché à la
concurrence mais elle le fait avec une
certitude elle a suffisamment d'atouts
pour tirer profit de cette nouvelle
compétition
la grande-bretagne en fait c'est à
partir de demain que démarre en les
festivités du jubilé de la reine des
millions de personnes attendues dans les
rues de londres pour le cinquantenaire
de l'accession au trône d'elizabeth deux
derniers préparatifs
la rembourser dernière répétition avant
le grand jour pour les élèves de cette
école du gospel lundi prochain ils vont
chanter devant la reine alors évidemment
la pression est énorme
la fierté aussi il faut dire que
l'événement est important 50 ans de
règne pour elizabeth 2 ça se fête
alors depuis plusieurs jours à londres
ont repeint les bus de couleur jubilé
on s'entraîne comme ces cavaliers de la
garde qui essaie de ne rien laisser au
hasard et d'éviter ce genre de choses on
construit des estrades on répète comme
ces musiciennes qui pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du pays vont jouer
dans les jardins de buckingham
les jardins de buckingham palace
c'est ce qui rend l'événement
exceptionnel des centaines d'animations
et de réception soigneusement choisis
pour placer la monarchie au coeur de la
nation auront lieu dans tout le pays
tout le monde s'y est mis
même les industriels puisque un groupe
de sociétés britanniques a offert à la
reine cette magnifique limousine qu'elle
étrennera mardi prochain mais quelle que
soit la qualité des préparatifs et
l'importance de ces cérémonies ce jubilé
doit faire face à la terrible
concurrence du football plus de la
moitié des britanniques ont déclaré
qu'il préférait regarder la coupe du
monde à la télévision plutôt que le
jubilé de la reine
une proportion qui chez les hommes et
chez les jeunes passe nettement au
dessus de la barre des 70% des tennis et
sur france télévisions les
internationaux de roland garros compte
rendu de la journée avec la
qualification de venus williams et de
gustavo kuerten pour les huitièmes de
finale la française nathalie dechy a été
éliminée natonale dunks il n'a fallu que
quelques minutes pour évacuer le court
numéro 1 la fota ce colis suspect en
plein tournoi les démineurs n'ont pas
perdu tant sur le court d'à côté gustavo
kuerten s'est lui aussi montré très
efficace
le triple vainqueur de roland garros
s'est imposé devant le chilien gonzalez
cet après midi dont les tribunes les
supporteurs brésiliens avaient le
sourire
nathalie dechy elle n'a pas passé une
très bonne journée face à l'argentine
mahrez la française était donnée
favorite elle s'est bien battue
elle a même réussi un des plus beaux
points du tournoi mais elle s'est
inclinée en trois sets
je me sentais bien quoi et je hais je
savais que ça passerait un moment ou un
autre
c'est pour ça que même sur la balle de
match j'y crois pas que c'est que c'est
la fin quoi c'est aussi la fin du
tournoi pour kim clijters finaliste l'an
passé
la belge a été sévèrement battue par
l'argentine fernandez 6 4 6 0
kim clijters se consolera sûrement dans
les bras de son fiancé lleyton hewitt
le numéro 1 mondial poursuit sa route à
roland garros
aujourd'hui il a éliminé le néerlandais
schalken en quatre sets
musique avec le talent reconnu de gamme
sans garant jeures et compositeur de
nombreux succès de l'artiste écossais
vient de sortir son deuxième album où se
mélangent subtilement le classique et
l'électronique qu'olivier les usa et
allemagne
il vit à glasgow
mais c'est peut-être à quelques
kilomètres de là dans les highlands que
sa musique puis sont mous des grands
espaces
armstrong diplômé de l'académie royale
de musique de londres n s'isoler dans
son studio entre ciel et terre
là il dessine des mélodies comme celle
que vous entendez que tout le monde
connaît sans jamais savoir qu'il a
ciselé
je peux entendre une musique quelque
part et je ne réalise même pas que c'est
la mienne
que ce soit dans un café ou ailleurs car
une fois écrit la musique me semble déjà
bien loin
moulin rouge
une musique de film inventé ici par lui
il lui moulin rouge roméo et juliette
mission impossible batman forever
et puis toutes les collaborations avec
massive attack texas madonna youtube
york
à composer 1 c'est ici que je compose
tous les arrangements électroniques et
puis après quand je fais les cordes
je dois trouver un lieu plus vaste
la musique du deuxième album de craig
amstrong se promène dans les rues de new
york offre un voyage dans différents
univers
quand
armstrong et laisse une empreinte une
douce mélancolie une beauté triste
ainsi se termine ce journal dans un
instant la météo nathalie rihouet plus
le point route valérie maurice 20h50
nestor burma avec guy marchand 0,35 le
dernier journal présenté par eve mettez
de master dans thé ou café
car il c'est là que soit la comédienne
caroline silhol quant à moi j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver dès 13 heures
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2